For this quiz, your goal is to finish the Appetizer class. We've provided the
complete code for the MainDish and the start for the Appetizer's class. Your
goal is to finish the Appetizer class to get the behavior shown. So, we'll
import both MainDish and Appetizer from the dish dot pie module. We can create
an Appetizer instance, passing in a name and a price. As well as an optional
parameter, where we've given a value for the parameter serves to be 23, instead
of the default value, which is 1. And we can see that prints out as Fried Python
$101.30. We can create another Appetizer, the Call-a-Mari dish, which is even
better than the call a method dish, which is vegetarian and serves three. We see
we get the star here, showing that it's a vegetarian dish. We can also create
main dishes and you don't have to do anything to change the MainDish code, but
you should preserve this behavior. So, see if you can modify the appetizer class
to get all the behavior I've shown here. You'll note that I've used somethings
in the MainDish class you might not have seen before. But I think you'll still
be able to figure out how to do this.